Traduttore: Roberto Minelli
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Allora BB-8, vediamo
se oggi vuoi collaborare?
Dovete scusarci,
perché questa è la nostra
prima presentazione interattiva,
e quindi siamo tutti e due
abbastanza tesi.
Hello!
Eh … Saluti? Non saluti...
Hai intenzione di collaborare, oggi?
Dai, che abbiamo poco tempo.
Go to sleep!
BB-8?
BB-8!
Go to sleep!
Va bene - dovete scusarlo, è un po' teso.
Allora, adesso ti spengo -
ti spengo, perché dobbiamo
parlare di cose serie.
Vediamo se ci riusciamo.
Dai, stai zitto un pochino!
Scusateci.
Questo è il mio mondo.
E questo è il mio sogno:
un futuro in cui i robot
saranno fra di noi,
in ogni campo del quotidiano
e, possibilmente, ci aiuteranno
in tutti i task della nostra giornata:
al lavoro, a scuola,
magari ci aiuteranno a fare i compiti -
però, purtroppo, questa immagine
è abbastanza lontana per il momento,
chiaramente perché i robot
sono sistemi complicati
dal punto di vista ingegneristico;
ma una parte su cui
bisogna fare tanto lavoro, ancora,
è l'interfaccia.
Perché, chiaramente,
per poter utilizzare un robot
bisogna avere un'interfaccia intuitiva,
senza doversi leggere
2000 pagine di manuale
soltanto per accenderlo.
In questo momento,
una tipica interfaccia per macchine
anche abbastanza semplici
è questa.
Vi sfido a utilizzare questa lavatrice
senza aver mai letto il manuale;
vi sfido a utilizzare una delle lavatrici
che abbiamo noi a Tokyo
senza avere idea di cosa significhino
i kanji che ci sono sopra;
e, chiaramente, vi lascio immaginare
quali sono le interfacce che utilizziamo
per robot un pochettino più complessi.
Ma come facciamo per costruire
un’interfaccia veramente intuitiva?
È interessante sapere
che, da parecchi studi, è emerso
che noi tendiamo a interfacciarci
con le macchine, con i dispositivi,
in maniera tanto più naturale –
come se ci stessimo interfacciando
con un'altra persona –
quanto più questi dispositivi
sono tecnologicamente avanzati.
Sicuramente, per me
è stato di grande conforto,
perché trovarmi a gridare al GPS
quando mi ha portato
a sperdere chissà dove
mi ha fatto sentire un po' stupida –
ma è scientificamente provato
che è una cosa naturale,
per noi, fare questo.
Quindi, per costruire
un’interfaccia intuitiva,
la cosa migliore sarebbe partire
da come noi ci interfacciamo
con le altre persone.
Quindi abbiamo preso
un modello di interazione umana -
che, come vedete, è un po' complesso,
perché non soltanto entra in gioco
quello che l'altra persona dice o fa
nel costruire la nostra risposta,
ma è importante anche
l'atteggiamento dell'altra persona,
il contesto generale dell'interazione.
E questi due -
tutti questi fattori
sono presi in considerazione
da due processi paralleli:
i processi cognitivi
e i processi emozionali.
Il processo cognitivo, fondamentalmente,
è tutto l'insieme di ragionamenti logici
che noi facciamo
e che ci portano a costruire
una risposta diretta, sensata,
possibilmente logica e razionale,
all'azione o alla domanda
dell'altra persona.
I processi emozionali, invece,
non sempre sono razionali.
Tengono parte di molti altri fattori
di cui, certe volte, noi siamo all'oscuro
da un punto di vista di pensiero
e portano, a volte,
a risposte del tutto impreviste.
Quindi è importante,
per costruire un’interfaccia
del tutto intuitiva,
essere in grado
di interpretare correttamente
e anche rispondere correttamente
a entrambi questi processi.
Infatti, secondo molti studi,
uno dei più importanti
è quello di Mehrabian,
soltanto il 7 percento dell'interazione
è data da azioni dirette
o parole - il linguaggio.
Tutto il resto si svolge
in maniera indiretta,
tramite il linguaggio del corpo,
tramite i cambi di toni di voce.
E tutto questo deve essere preso
in considerazione dal robot,
per essere in grado
di interfacciarsi con noi
in maniera intuitiva e diretta.
Un concetto interessante,
per noi roboticisti,
è il concetto di Uncanny Valley-
o “valle perturbante”,
come è tradotto su Wikipedia -
o magari un po' più intelligentemente
come “zona del disagio”.
Questa teoria afferma che,
quanto più un oggetto è simile -
un oggetto, un robot,
è simile ad una persona
nel suo … nella sua interazione,
prendendo in considerazione
tutti gli aspetti dell'interazione –
non soltanto l'apparenza fisica,
il modo di muoversi, il modo di porsi,
il modo di parlare –,
quanto più noi tendiamo
a essere a nostro agio,
proprio come se ci stessimo interfacciando
con una persona normale.
C’è però un punto in cui si cade
nella zona del disagio,
in cui quando questo
oggetto, questo robot,
è molto simile all'uomo
ma uno di questi fattori
non è all'altezza,
non è come ce lo aspettiamo noi,
che noi entriamo - sentiamo
una sensazione spiacevole,
una sensazione di disagio,
non riusciamo più a interfacciarci
in maniera corretta
e cerchiamo di interrompere l’interazione.
Questo è dato da una nostra
risposta emozionale
ad un’incongruenza dell'emozione -
della risposta emozionale,
generalmente del robot.
Quindi le emozioni sono il ponte
che ci permette di superare
la zona del disagio
e far sì che riusciamo -
che i robot riescano a essere
veramente interattivi,
come noi ce lo aspettiamo.
In sostanza, se voi
avete letto questo libro,
se gli uomini sono da Marte
e le donne vengono da Venere,
e devono imparare
a comunicare fra di loro
secondo le aspettative l'uno dell'altro
perché altrimenti
non si arriva a un dialogo,
i robot vengono dalla Terra
e anche loro hanno bisogno
di interfacciarsi con noi
secondo le nostre aspettative.
In sostanza,
per costruire un’interfaccia
completamente intuitiva uomo-robot,
il robot deve essere in grado sì,
di saper interpretare correttamente
e rispondere sul canale cognitivo
con risposte dirette a domande dirette-
risposte dirette a azioni dirette;
ma deve essere anche in grado
di interpretare correttamente,
e rispondere, sul canale emozionale.
Un po' più indiretto, un po' più sottile
e che però, certe volte,
è completamente opposto
al canale cognitivo.
Chiaramente,
i robot devono sapere
interpretare le emozioni,
per poterci rispondere correttamente;
ma non devono, come si pensa,
provare emozioni.
Perché?
Proprio perché le emozioni
sono frutto di ragionamenti,
processi non del tutto razionali,
e possono portare a risposte impreviste.
Noi non vogliamo che il robot
abbia risposte impreviste:
noi vogliamo che il robot risponda
esattamente come noi ce lo aspettiamo,
per cui non vogliamo trovarci
a litigare con il robot - così.
Per cui, è importante questa distinzione.
Ma da un punto di vista pratico,
come si svolge la comunicazione?
Dunque, abbiamo detto
che la maggior parte della comunicazione
si svolge su un piano non verbale;
all'interno dei segnali non verbali
ci sono segnali consci,
che noi facciamo sapendo di fare,
e segnali inconsci
di cui non siamo del tutto...
consci, giustamente.
Dunque, questi segnali si dividono in:
segnali vocali, paralinguaggio,
tutto quello che non è linguaggio diretto,
le esclamazioni, i cambi di toni di voce;
e poi c'è il linguaggio
del corpo, i movimenti.
Inoltre, ci sono segnali
del tutto emozionali,
segnali che sono gesti codificati,
gesti di cui tutti, comunque,
conoscono il significato –
basti pensare, se io punto
in una certa direzione.
A metà fra i gesti codificati
e i segnali emozionali,
ci sono i gesti creativi,
che sono generalmente utilizzati nell’arte
e che sono gesti che noi
facciamo sapendo di fare,
ma che vogliono esternare
una particolare emozione.
Un robot deve sapere correttamente
interpretare tutti questi segnali
e rispondere correttamente
a tutti questi segnali.
Fisicamente noi come interagiamo?
Fisicamente noi usiamo il nostro corpo.
Ci sono parecchi cambiamenti in atto,
nel corpo, durante l'interazione.
Alcuni cambiamenti sono visibili –
l'espressione facciale,
il movimento del corpo;
alcuni cambiamenti sono invisibili,
e generalmente sono proprio i cambiamenti
dovuti alle risposte emozionali.
Per esempio:
cambiamenti nel battito cardiaco;
nella respirazione;
la pressione sanguigna che sale a mille
quando uno si arrabbia, eccetera.
Dunque, noi uomini,
generalmente abbiamo tutti i cinque sensi,
che sono pochi,
ma sono capaci di interpretare
segnali molto complessi,
e con questi segnali molto -
questi cinque sensi,
noi interpretiamo, generalmente,
soltanto la parte visibile
dei cambiamenti del corpo,
quindi le espressioni facciali, la voce,
i cambi di toni di voce,
i movimenti del corpo.
Quindi un robot, per essere in grado
di interfacciarsi con noi
in maniera intuitiva,
deve essere in grado
di muoversi correttamente,
rispondere correttamente,
tono di voce corretto
e fare espressioni facciali,
in caso abbia il viso, corrette.
Per quanto riguarda i robot, invece,
ce ne sono tanti tipi,
di tante dimensioni, di tante forme
e generalmente sono dotati
di tantissimi tipi di sensori diversi,
che però sono in grado di processare
soltanto segnali molto semplici.
Per cui, per un robot,
per costruirsi il più possibile
un'immagine corretta
della situazione globale –
quindi sia cognitiva che emozionale,
nostra, del loro partner –
devono essere in grado
di utilizzare i loro sensori
per captare tutte le variazioni possibili
del corpo di chi sta interagendo con loro.
E quindi, fondamentalmente,
io sono diventata la psico-fisiologa,
come dicevano ieri, dei robot.
[È] interessante, [il fatto che] noi
lavoriamo soprattutto con gli umanoidi,
per cui abbiamo fatto studi
sulla postura degli umanoidi –
chiaramente,
se un robot vuole esprimere felicità,
deve avere una postura corretta;
se vuole esprimere tristezza,
avrà una postura diversa.
Tutti gli studi sono stati fatti
su persone normali, generalmente su video,
e applicati a robot.
Un robot dotato di viso umanoide -
sempre nostro, del nostro laboratorio -
deve essere in grado
di produrre espressioni facciali
che assomiglino il più possibile
a quelle che facciamo noi
durante le nostre interazioni emozionali.
Nel caso mio, io lavoro
con il robot sassofonista
che deve interpretare in questo video
i gesti creativi della ballerina,
estrarre l'informazione emotiva
che la ballerina vuole esprimere
e riprodurla con un
mezzo diverso, la musica.
E adesso, per farvi capire
quanto in realtà sia molto
più sottile l'interazione,
ho portato il mio assistente,
che però è un po' birichino
e non so se vuole collaborare.
E questo per farvi vedere che un robot,
che non è umanoide,
che non ha una faccia,
che non ha grandi possibilità
di comunicare, se non quella vocale,
è in grado lo stesso, possibilmente,
di generare qualche risposta emotiva -
vediamo se ce la facciamo.
BB-8, sei pronto?
Hello!
No, no, non ti buttare,
che già ci hai provato ieri.
Vuoi salutare la folla, sì o no?
È spaventato, chiaramente,
perché è veramente la prima volta
che noi facciamo
una presentazione interattiva.
Sì, sì, sì, non ti preoccupare,
non ti preoccupare -
Però è contento di essere qui.
Va bene, che facciamo, ce ne andiamo?
Saluta tutti.
Ce la facciamo, BB-8?
Va bene, grazie.
(Applausi)